this video is kindly sponsored by fast
hosts
if you're based in the uk you have the
chance to win the ultimate work from
home setup
worth up to 5000 pounds if
you can answer my techie test question
that is link in the description
and i'll explain more later on in the
video hey
42 here many of us grew up with a
favorite number
it was a bit of a necessity really
what's your favorite number was one of
those
important questions kids use to decide
if others were
worthy of their time along with who's
your favorite ninja turtle
and are you with the rebellion or the
empire
and not everyone grows out of it
marissa mayer former ceo of yahoo
has a thing for highly divisible numbers
like 12
people around the world seem to be drawn
to the number seven
and we all know someone who has to have
the volume set to an even number
but when it comes to forming an
unhealthily strong attachment to numbers
few of us have taken it quite as far as
the ancient greek philosopher pythagoras
you'll probably recognize his name from
those excruciatingly dull maths lessons
of your childhood
so let me dig those painful memories
back up for you
pythagoras's theorem states that if you
take a right
angled triangle square its two shorter
sides
and add the results together the answer
will equal the square
of the longest side the hypotenuse
or expressed with algebra a to the power
of two
plus b to the power of two equals c to
the power of two
funnily enough it turns out this simple
equation
undoubtedly one of the most famous in
the whole of mathematics
wasn't actually discovered by pythagoras
at all
in fact it was in use in ancient babylon
a good thousand years or so before
pythagoras was born
sometime around 570 bc how exactly
pythagoras's name came to be
inextricably associated with a theorem
that was already
ancient when he was born is unknown
what's also unknown are many of the
details about pythagoras's life
and that's a shame because what we do
know
is downright bizarre you see
pythagoras it turns out was the leader
of a strange cult that worshipped
numbers
and had some extremely weird practices
so without further ado here's what they
didn't tell you
in maths class fast hosts is a uk-based
web hosting company which offers a wide
range of products to bring your projects
to life
fast hosts aims to support uk businesses
and entrepreneurs
at all levels with affordable hosting
solutions
you probably already know that if you're
looking to start a new business
or perhaps just a blog you're going to
need a web presence
that's where fast host can help you by
offering everything you need from
domain name starting at one pound and a
fantastic
web builder and once you're ready to go
live you can use their reliable and
secure
web hosting with unlimited bandwidth
personally i love their cloud backup
service
making these videos uses a ton of
storage with fast hosts cloud backup
i can seamlessly backup my data and
should the worst happen
i can recover it in minutes test it out
today by getting five gigabytes of cloud
backup
absolutely free uk viewers have the
chance to win the ultimate work from
home setup
worth up to 5 000 pounds if you can
answer my techie test question
they asked me to write an employee of
which
company invented the usb port
visit the link in the description to
answer my question
and enter the competition today don't
miss out
pythagoras was born in samos a beautiful
greek island that was known for its
talented engineers
and lively festivals he was fascinated
with maths
and astronomy from a young age and
studied under several well-respected
scholars
one of them a wise old man who went by
the name of thales
encouraged young pythagoras to pack up
his things
and head to egypt which was apparently
the place to be for anyone who wanted to
learn about life the universe and
everything
pythagoras must have really liked egypt
because he spent the next two decades of
his life there
keeping himself busy by learning to
speak egyptian visiting temples
and having lengthy profound
conversations with the local priests
about the best way to achieve spiritual
purity
after egypt was invaded by the persians
pythagoras was taken to babylon
as a prisoner of war where he happily
hung out with a bunch of
occult astrology priests known as the
magi
he was instructed in their sacred rites
found out all about their mystical
worship of the gods
and basically became what can be best
described
as a maths wizard we don't really know
how pythagoras escaped the babylonians
perhaps he simply smotes them down with
bolts of concentrated
mass lightning but whether weaponized
mafs was involved or not
he returned to samos around 520 bc once
back in his hometown
he formed a school called the semicircle
i'm guessing this was before he
discovered his deep
love of triangles and this became
the place to discuss justice goodness
and all those other concepts the ancient
greeks enjoyed
philosophizing about pythagoras himself
however
preferred to spend his time alone in his
man cave outside the city
after a couple of years in samos
pythagoras moved once again
this time to croton in southern italy
there
he used his charisma and charm to climb
the political ladder and eventually
serve as an advisor to the elites
the local authorities were so impressed
with his intellect
they asked him to set up a school and
pass on his immense learning to the
young people of croton
but when they said school
what pythagoras apparently heard
was crazy ass religious maths cult
because his students who came to be
known as
pythagoreans developed some of the
strangest practices
in history to gain entry to pythagoras's
cult
sorry school you couldn't just
rock up and take a seat somewhere at the
back you had to undertake
a three-year probation period during
this
time you'd be judged on everything from
how you responded to criticism to the
way you laughed
you'd also be tested on your memory
concentration
and speed of thought once you were in
triangle club there was a strict
hierarchy
members were divided into the acousa
matikoi or
listeners and the mathematicoi or
learners the listeners formed the outer
circle and focused on the spiritual
teachings
they also had to take a five-year vow of
silence
yep five friggin years during which
they'd listened to pythagoras deliver
his sermons
from behind a veil i'm guessing this
wasn't because pythagoras was just
really shy
it was probably to create a sense of
mystique for his
eager newbies the learners formed
the inner circle and it was their job to
progress the intellectual discoveries of
the group
to access this elite faction you had to
give up
all your possessions and live with other
learners
this kind of sacrifice is still common
amongst cults today
the members of people's temple a cult in
which over 900 people took part in a
mass suicide
in guyana in the late 70s for example
were required to give up their
belongings and homes
at the very top of this hierarchy of
course was pythagoras himself
and what a ruler he was cult leaders
often make outlandish claims about their
gifts and abilities
the leader of the people's temple jim
jones claimed he could heal people
and charles manson claims to have
invented god
but none have managed to live up to
pythagoras
according to legend he could speak to
animals
he had a thigh made of gold who doesn't
want one of those
he could remember previous lives and
he was a demi-god supposedly the son of
apollo
he could also predict earthquakes stop
the wind blowing
and calm the sea's waves so just
generally a very useful guy to have
around
pythagoras sets some very strict rules
for his followers some
made a lot of sense such as exercising
and not eating food that's fallen on the
floor my sources were unclear on how he
felt about the three-second rule
others were more restrictive like living
in austere lifestyle
and having a vegetarian diet but
then it all starts to get a little weird
well
weirder to be a true pythagorean
you had to avoid public roads you
couldn't pee
towards the sun you had to wear white
clothes
and you had to take your right shoe off
before you left
you were forbidden from sharing the
secrets of the cult with any outsiders
and perhaps to prevent those same
outsiders from coming too close
you were encouraged not to wash
you couldn't break bread at the table
because bread stood for friendship
and the biggest sin of all to eat
a fava bean was utterly unforgivable
because the beans were closely
associated with reincarnation
basically the pythagoreans believed that
fava beans
contained the souls of their dead
ancestors
and so eating one was akin to
cannibalism
and absolutely prohibited yes even with
some liver and a nice chianti
they also had to practice abstinence
which let's be honest
probably wasn't the biggest challenge
for members of a maths cult
pythagoras believe that when we um
eject our various bodily fluids and
gases we lose part of our soul
so sex was off the cards as was
letting one rip though i should point
out it seems pythagoras himself
didn't always follow this rule since he
supposedly had several
children with a lady from crete so
we know that getting into the group was
challenging to say the least
and their way of living was a little
eccentric but what was it all for
what did the pythagoreans actually
believe in
well we can split their beliefs into two
main tenets
the pursuit of spiritual salvation and
the pursuit of knowledge
at the core of the spiritual tenet was
metampsychosis
or the transmigration of souls the
pythagoreans believed that
after we die our souls live on and enter
a new body presumably one that isn't
already occupied
or things could get a little awkward the
ultimate goal
similar to buddhism was to escape the
endless cycle of reincarnations
and gain true immortality to achieve
this pythagoreans aims to keep their
bodies morally pure
through rigorous self-discipline which
leads us to the second tenet the pursuit
of knowledge
the study of the cosmic order would
allow pythagoreans to reach ultimate
union
with the divine cosmos and things like
philosophy and
music were a means to purify the spirit
and come closer to the gods
and out of all the ancient greek gods
which do you think the pythagoreans
worshiped
was it apollo the widely revered god of
music and poetry
or perhaps athena the watchful and
intelligent goddess of wisdom
no it was ten not a god called
ten the number ten you see
pythagoreans believed that reality is
essentially
mathematical in nature and that
everything can be reduced
to numbers this was summarized by their
overriding dictum
all is number and of all the numbers
none was more sacred than 10.
the importance of the number 10 is
perfectly expressed by the group's holy
symbol
the tetractus a triangle made up of ten
points
it shows that when we add together the
first four numbers
that's one two three and four for those
of you at the back
they form a perfect equilateral triangle
the pythagoreans prayed to the tatractus
describing it as the mother of all
the comprising all bounding the
firstborn
that never swerving that's never tiring
holy ten key holder of all
so yeah they took their numbers pretty
seriously
and they didn't like having their
beliefs challenged either
which is why when a man called hippesus
came along
and questioned one of the main doctrines
of pythagoreanism
things didn't go so well for him you see
the pythagoreans placed a lot of
importance on their belief that
all things could be qualified using a
ratio of whole numbers
but then hippis a pythagorean himself
only went and discovered irrational
numbers
he proved to his peers that if you take
a right angle triangle
with two sides with a length of one you
can use pythagoras theorem to show that
the hypotenuse
is the square root of two but the square
root of
2 is an irrational number its decimal
expansion goes on forever
never repeating itself so how do you
think the pythagoreans dealt with this
unpleasant revelation a firm reprimand
perhaps
or maybe another five years silence well
according to one account pythagoras was
so disgusted with hypocessors audacity
he sentenced him to death by drowning
yeah
nothing like a bit of murder to keep
your other followers in check eh
but according to others his death wasn't
anything to do with irrational numbers
hippis had apparently broken the first
rule of pythagoras club
he talked about pythagoras club he had
revealed the properties of the
dodecahedron
a solid with 12 sides to the masses
just imagine what that kind of knowledge
could do
in the wrong hands yeah
towards the end of pythagoras life
croton came into conflict with a
neighboring city-state
siberis siberis was known back then for
its
love of excess and military power so
much so that people with excessively
large vocabularies
apparently used the word ciborite to
describe
someone overly keen on luxury and
pleasure
when the leader of the civilis demanded
the return of some refugees
who'd fled to croton pythagoras rallied
the kretonians
and one of his followers called milo the
wrestler apparently he was really handy
in a fight
and attacked cyborus leaving it in ruins
you know your city is ill-defended when
it's flattened to the ground
by the maths club but following this
decisive victory
some prominent citizens of croton
suggested a new style of leadership
democracy pythagoras shockingly enough
wasn't on board with that and so they
rused the populace against him
they attacked the pythagoreans during
one of their meetings
and sets their building on fire
depending on who you believe
pythagoras was either at the meeting and
perished
he was at the meeting and escaped or he
was somewhere else entirely
some say that as the house was burning
to the ground
pythagoras's devoted followers laid
themselves down on the flames
to make a path for him to escape after
which he committed suicide because he
was so traumatized
there's no helping some people but my
personal favorite version of events
is this pythagoras having managed to
escape the fire
was pursued by his enemies he nearly
managed to escape
but then came across a field of fava
beans
rather than go against his own teachings
and touched
the sacred father beans he stopped in
his tracks
and was violently killed as a result
he may have been an absolute nutter but
you have to hand it to him the man had
principles
after pythagoras died his teachings
lived on through his successors
and pythagorean schools didn't disappear
fully
until the 4th century bc and although
written accounts of the man himself
are hard to come by and historians don't
agree on all the aspects of his life
his teachings have influenced the
philosophies of aristotle
plato and through them western
philosophy
itself even today numerology the belief
in some kind of relationship between
numbers and events
is still very much a thing and any
physicist searching for
the theory of everything or some kind of
numerical answer to the ultimate
question of life
is when you think about it a pythagorean
so i guess that includes me thanks for
watching
[Music]
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts
available on youtube spotify apple
podcast
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
link in the description below
thanks